a psychedelic point of view means a  point of view which honors consciousness  consciousness is seen as the value to be  maximized that's what we want we want  more consciousness better integration  better information better models we  don't want to petrify ourselves or  commit ourselves to a model that somehow  then is found to be a obsolete and the  inadequate  so what chiefly constitutes the  psychedelic point of view I think is  it's open-ended and provisional nature  as opposed to every other ideology or  point of view that's running around we  have to what what the psychedelic point  of view  is a kind of cultural relativism we're  trying to get a grip on who and where we  are in the cosmos from a point of view  not that of the American consumerist  citizen something else something larger  deeper broader more touched by the  cosmic more  sense of the past and of destiny